There are various properties of images formed
by spherical mirrors… the
position, the size, and the nature of the
image. These properties vary as the
object’s distance from the mirror varies.
The property that we are going to
discuss in detail in this video is the SIZE
of the image.
For a concave mirror, there are three possibilities
for the size of the image
relative to the object! Basically, the image
can be enlarged, the image can be
of the same size or can also be diminished
or smaller in size.
For a convex mirror, the image is always smaller
in size unless the object
touches the mirror! In that case, the image
will be of the same size as the
object.
Now if we were to compare the size of the
image with the size of the object,
then we will take their ratios. That is, the
ratio of size of the image to the size
of the object. And this ratio is what we call
MAGNIFICATION. It is denoted by
‘m’. Let’s move to a new page!
In our ray diagram, the sizes of the object
and the image are nothing but the
heights of the object and image. So ‘m’
will be equal to ‘h i over h o’. Let’s
do a
bit of math now. Suppose the height of the
image is greater than the height of
the object. This means that image is enlarged.
Now answer this question. If the term in the
numerator is greater than the
term in the denominator, then the ratio will
be?
Yes, their ratio will be greater than one.
What if ‘h i is less than h o’? Yes, the
ratio will be less than one. The image is
DIMINISHED.
What if they are equal? Their equality implies
that both the object and image
are of SAME size. The ratio will be one!
If you notice that in all the three cases
we are assuming something. We are
assuming both h o and h i to be non-zero.
But can they be zero?
We know that when the object is at infinity,
its point sized image is formed at
the focal point. So here we can take size
of the image as zero. However
theoretically we say that when the object
is at infinity, the image is point sized.
But in reality, this is not a point sized
image, because we cannot define infinity.
The image, however small it is, still has
some dimensions. So in reality, h i
cannot be zero. It can be a really small number,
for example, zero point zero
zero zero zero zero five but never zero. We
can apply the same logic for the
object size. So h i and h o cannot be zero
in reality.
Now there is a relation between the magnification
and the object distance ‘u’
and image distance ‘v’. the relation is
that ‘h i’ over ‘h o’ is equal to
negative
v over u.
This relation is very easy to prove. I will
give you rough sketch of its proof in
another video in this playlist, but first
let us solve a few problems based on
magnification.
Here’s the first problem!
A side-view convex mirror of an automobile
has its radius of curvature as 3m. If
a bus is located 5m away from this mirror,
then find the
a. position of the image
b. nature of the image
c. ratio of the ‘size of the image’ to
the ‘size of the object’
We will see the solution in the next part
of the video!